on m'avait gas mais oui on va les gars
on va les gars sûr qu'on va vegas c'est
parti
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver aujourd'hui parce que je
vous emmène pour un trip on va partir à
las vegas on va partir au cs et on y va
ensemble
et justement on a plein de choses à voir
ensemble sur ce sujet je vous explique
la tenue il ya plusieurs choses à savoir
je vous en parle depuis un moment j'ai
prévu de partir aux crs à las vegas donc
c'est bon ça c'est fait c'est acté ont
pas est bien évidemment pas tout seul je
vous emmène avec moi dans mes bagages
alors qu'est ce qu'on va aller faire à
vegas on va aller au cs on va regarder
les nouvelles tendances aller voir ce
qui se passe donc je fais le cvs en
entier je serai là le matin à
l'ouverture
je serai là le soir à la fermeture pas
passer cinq jours cinq jours entiers aux
crs à se balader et pendant ces cinq
jours vous amène avec moi je sortirai
bien évidemment une vidéo plutôt vlok
généralistes par jour pour vous montrer
un petit peu ce que j'ai vu et je vous
sortir est peut-être une à deux vidéos
en plus par jour
vidéo plus produit pour va faire
vraiment un focus sur les grands
produits et les produits super
intéressant alors ça c'est pendant tout
le temps du cms
après je sortirai d'autres vidéos où
j'aurai tourne effectivement aux crs
pour vous montrer les tendances les
produits des choses hyper intéressante
et passionnante alors on va s'arrêter
énormément parce qu'il va y avoir
forcément de la téléphonie mobile
on va forcément parler de télé on va
parler d'audio on va parler de voitures
connectées
on va parler de robotique on va parler
des entreprises françaises french tech
qui seront présentes également à las
vegas il y aura énormément de choses et
s'en va le voir ensemble donc vegas bien
évidemment il fera pas trop froid il
devrait faire à peu près 20 degrés c'est
sensiblement le train tant par rapport à
ce qu'on a
en france en tout cas ici donc ça
devrait pas trop mal par contre juste
avant pour vous faire plaisir
j'ai dit tiens si on se faisait un petit
trip à new york et j'arrive le samedi 6
janvier
il fera moins 12 ans journée et moins 15
ans avec un petit vent de nord-ouest à
45 kilomètres heure autant vous dire que
ces gars là c'est un peu fou chaîne
cailler les miches donc j'ai prévu bien
évidemment le joli poupon
il a d'abord sow est justement tout ça
je vais partager avec vous je vous
emmène vous dans mes bagages
il va y avoir énormément de choses
pendant ce séjour mais la toute première
chose que je veux si vous voulez c'est
pas que moi et j'ai tout seul et que je
vous montre ce que j'ai vu je veux
vraiment vous participiez si ça vous
intéresse c'est bien sur ce que je vous
demande c'est en commentaire dès
maintenant laissez moi vos questions
quels sont les sujets qui vous
intéressent
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que je vends
priorité est ce qu'il ya des produits
plus qu'un autre que vous voulez que je
vois est ce qu'il y a des marques plus
qu'une autre que vous voulez savoir est
ce que vous vouliez voir en priorité
samsung huawei est ce que vous voulez
que j'aille vraiment faire des focus sur
la french tech voir un peu les nouveaux
produits influence parce que voulez vous
aller voir les voitures connectées
est ce que vous voulez que j'aille voir
tesla est ce que vous voulez que j'aille
voir je ne sais pas valoir va y avoir
tout c'est vraiment la grande messe de
la high tech qui à las vegas est le plus
gros salon était que monde donc sera
tout et tout le monde peut être pas
apple on verra donc vous me mettez tout
sans commentaires dites moi absolument
s'ouvrir je regarde parce que ça c'est
super intéressant et je veux surtout me
faire plaisir et vous faire plaisir
partager tout ça avec vous donc ce qu'on
fera comme je voulais 10 des vidéos tous
les jours vlog donc laissez moi bien vos
réactions dessous dites moi tiens ça
c'était cool ça veut dire cool est ce
que tu peux plus de détails est ce que
tu peux parler de ça il posément toutes
vos questions
toutes les questions qui vous viennent à
la tête vous me posez à ses premiers
points le deuxième point c'est à new
york
alors qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
j'aille voir à new york qu'est ce qui
vous ferait plaisir
est ce que vaut le visa y voir l'apple
store est ce que vous voulez que j'aille
voir quelque chose en particulier
alors c'est pour me dire à la statue de
la liberté où l'homme par ailleurs state
building ou le one world trade center
je pense pas que ce soit super
intéressant je les ai passé deux jours à
l'aller et au retour je vais passer une
journée
donc on a largement le temps de
s'organiser donc dites moi vraiment ce
qui vous ferait plaisir
et le troisième point pour qu'on profité
de l'occasion pour faire une faq
franchement
est-ce que ça déchirait pas de se dire
on serait une faq à new york même s'il
fait moins 11 et que je fais ma faq
dehors - 11 mai avec du soleil donc
puisque y aura du soleil op
alla donc même s'il fait moins 11 même
si fra - 11 même si on va se tailler les
niches
ça peut aussi être super intéressant
d'organiser une faq une vraie afin qu
toutes les questions que vous vous posez
sur la chaîne youtube toutes les
questions vous voulez me poser je vous
répondrais je ne cacherai rien du tout
je vous dirai tout je partagerai tout
alors je compte sur vous pour pas être
trop indiscrets à me demander la taille
de mon slip me demandez quelle odeur ont
mes chaussettes le soir à sa ces choses
qui sont pas très intéressantes mais
voilà donc je n'éluderai aucune question
et ça j'ai revu les partager avec vous
et je pense que faire ça à new york
ça va vraiment déchiré je vous invite
une fois de plus ah mais c'est tout son
commentaire et à poser toutes vos
questions
maintenant qu'on va faire c'est que je
vais vous présenter un peu mon trip et
je vais vous montrer ce qui va se passer
alors pour ça je veux un petit peu moins
déshabiller si vous ne voyez pas
d'inconvénient parce que pour l'instant
je suis pas encore parti est ici fait
chaud il ya évidemment alors je vous
montrais je vais partir de suisse je
vais décollé de genève pourquoi je riais
me diriez-vous tout simplement parce que
il faut savoir qu'il ya des bons plans
au départ de genève
si vous voulez partir pour pas trop cher
vous pouvez partir de genève ou de
bruxelles
il ya plein de vols qui sont moins cher
qu'au départ paris je vais à genève et
ensuite je prends l'avion genève et new
york
new york j'arrive le samedi 6 janvier
vers 15 heures je vais pouvoir passer
toute ma fin de journée du samedi
tout mon dimanche complet directement
ici et ensuite le lundi je pars
direction vegas vegas j'arrive le lundi
fin d'après midi le soir j'ai une
surprise
pendant cinq jours c es ça va être
dingue et ensuite je repars le dimanche
je retourne jusqu'à new york new york
j'y reste jusqu'au lundi soir donc je
pense qu on a moyen de faire des trucs
hyper cool et justement je compte sur
vous pour me dire ce que vous voulez ce
qui vous ferait plaisir donc bien
évidemment pour ce trip je me suis
équipé
j'ai emmené mon adaptateur pour pouvoir
le brancher sur les prises américaine
parce que sinon je prends rien faire
j'ai prévenu le super cartoville de
pénélope merci pénélope super outil est
bien évidemment les cartes de visite
monsieur re voilà ici à tout le monde
donc voilà un peu ce qui va se passer
pour ce voyage aux crs je compte
vraiment sur vous pour être présent avec
moi parce que je pense qu'on va voir des
trucs super cool on va kiffer ensemble
on va découvrir des choses de dingue
c'est vraiment un contenu sur lequel je
travaille depuis plus de six mois donc
je suis très content de pouvoir y aller
je pense qu'on va passer des moments
dingues et je compte sur vous pour faire
de cet accueil pour savoir ce que vous
voulez que je fasse pour savoir ce que
vous voulez qu'on voit ensemble et
maintenant concernant des routes vous
donne c'est à new-york directement au
united states of america à demain à new
york